bonjour madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors un nombre
faible 1,2 cas de coraux 9 avec deux
coronavirus la grèce comme le portugal
comment expliquer ce cas grec
oui alors c'est vrai que il ya soir le
ministre compétent annonçait 86 j quine
du virus alors que la grèce a à peu près
autant d'habitants que la région
ile-de-france maintenant alors les
raisons je suis comme tout le monde je
ne peux pas toujours j'en sais pas plus
mais disons que les différences par
rapport au traitement de la france ça a
été d'abord de réagir très vite c'est
vrai c'est à dire ce que en fait dès
qu'il ya eu les premiers cas recensés
qui étaient des congressistes qui
revenait d'italie la grèce a très vite
fermé
en fait ces frontières et tous les gens
qui venaient de l'étranger et terre en
fait mis en quarantaine pendant quinze
jours dans des hôtels
l'art est à l'heure actuelle le c'est
toujours le cas et puis il ya une
deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
les écoles ont fermé dès lé mois de
février il y en a une troisième c'est
que la grèce a des masques et des du gel
hydroalcoolique disponible dans les
pharmacies qui a été commandée dès la
fin du mois de janvier par les armateurs
ces fameuses armateurs qui payent pas
beaucoup d'impôts et à leurs frais et
pour l'instant il y en a encore alors
effectivement il se plaint que
maintenant les commandes ont le même
problème que pour tout le reste de
l'europe mais apparemment il avait fait
des stocks très tôt et puis la dernière
différence que j'ai repéré c'est aussi
quand même le sait ce que en france il
ya des départements comme la lozère où
il n'y a encore aucun mort du virus et
ya quand même pratiquement 3 6 60% de la
surface grecque qui n'est pas plus
peuplés si je puis dire que la lozère
donc ré c'est en fait les grandes villes
qui sont les
les foyers à surveiller et notamment la
capitale athènes alors autant bien là
déjà 40% de la population presque
par contre c'est vrai que je suis pas
tout à fait sûr que les cracks respecte
parfaitement soutenir justement ces
sages c'est la question que je voulais
vous poser on sent bien qu'il ya eu une
anticipation de la part du gouvernement
mais ce que les grecs sont disciplinés
comme les autres pays européens on voit
l'espagne on voit la grèce l'italie est
également complètement mis sous cloche
avec ce confinement est ce que les grecs
on sait cette notion de confinement je
joue je n'y suis pas donc je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit totalement disciplinés
mais en tout cas le premier ministre les
rappels à l'ordre je dirais quasiment
trois fois par semaine donc je crois que
ils ont bien compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose à la leur et celle altrad
week-end de pâques en fête le week-end
de pâques et on sait que c'est
d'ailleurs à cette période que il y a
beaucoup de
deux déplacements beaucoup de grecs qui
se trouve à athènes décide d'aller vers
les îles pour passer justement ce
week-end de pâques
la saison du tourisme va revenir très
vite l'été puisque c'est une destination
qui est qui est très prisé jusqu'à
maintenant on sait pas à quoi
ressemblera cet été mais ce que vous
pensez
que le gouvernement grec pourrait
décider
voilà un déconfinement assez rapidement
justement pour qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
répercussions négatif sur l'économie qui
est quand même l'économie et surtout le
tourisme
bien sûr mon cher pour l'instant il n'ya
pas d'avion dont claque faire et à peu
près réglé en ce qui concerne une
éventuelle arrivée de touristes immédiat
il ya aussi très peu de bateaux pour les
îles parce que la plupart des ils ont eu
très peur est en fait toutes les petites
filles dans laquelle il décale ya aucun
cas ont tout fait et supplier pour qu'
il n'y ait plus de bateaux donc est en
fait pour maintenir si j'ose dire leur
hymne l'immunité dans d'isolement
ensuite le gouvernement a l'air de
penser de dire que jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'avril le confinement restera mais
vous savez dans les supermarchés on a 3
1 un client par 10 mètres carrés il ya
quelqu'un à l'encré qui dispose d'autant
de petites marques qu'il y a que deux
fois dix mètres carrés mais quand quand
les petites marques sont épuisés dans on
attend que quelqu'un sorte pour faire
rentrer suivant avec la petite carte
très bien donc voilà la grèce qui prend
quand même beaucoup de dispositions pour
essayer d'endiguer cette crise du
coronavirus merci beaucoup joël
d'allègre d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maîtresse de conférences à l'inalco
spécialiste de la grecque contemporaine